bonjour je suis xavier hermès directeur
général de l'opérateur 00 c'est
l'opérateur pionnier du très haut débit
et de la fibre optique à la réunion une
société réunionnaise pour les
réunionnais avec bientôt 100
collaborateurs d'ubs basé à saint pierre
et au port et dans le nord puisque nous
sommes maintenant présents dans le nord
à sainte-marie et nous sommes une
société en forte croissance depuis trois
ans c'est pourquoi nous recrutons nous
recrutons des métiers techniques de
construction de réseaux d'ingénérie de
raccordement des abonnés et des métiers
commerciaux les métiers de la vente des
métiers de service client puisque notre
service client est entièrement basé au
port à la réunion
the hop c'est l'opérateur très haut
débit réunionnais pour les réunionnais
pour accompagner notre croissance nous
recrutons dans de nombreux métiers
techniques et commerciaux et nous
recherchons de façon urgente des
releveurs négociateurs
rattaché à la direction de la conception
du réseau vous aurez pour mission de
préparer l'arrivée de la fibre optique
dans les eaux comme dans les bars et
dans l'ensemble des villes de la réunion
vous êtes autonome vous avez le sens du
contact vous avez un vrai sens de la
technique vous avez un permis b
rejoignez nous pour préparer l'arrivée
des câbles dans tous les quartiers pour
nous livrer nous recrutons un ingénieur
commercial on serait directement
rattaché au directeur de la division
entreprises et vous aurez pour mission
de proposer aux pme et grands comptes de
la réunion nos offres voix data internet
vous avez une bonne maîtrise des réseaux
télécoms vous avez le sens de
l'engagement
vous êtes dynamique rejoignez nous pour
ce poste à pourvoir en cdi pour nous
accompagner sur la croissance du marché
en photo